monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
merci à mon groupe de me permettre de
présenter ce texte
aujourd'hui merci à monique lubin qui
s'exprimera en notre monde en quelques
minutes et à jean luc richer pour la
qualité sans rapport bien que les votes
émis en commission ne soit pas en
concordance avec les constats dressés
je tiens également à remercier le
professeur de droit stéphane bern ac et
maître jérôme justice pour leurs
conseils avisés ainsi que saluer brahim
benali syndicaliste dit nv vtc arthur et
de la cgt livreurs et tous les
travailleurs qui se lève dans ce combat
chers collègues
c'est la cinquième fois en moins de
trois ans que nous nous retrouvons dans
cet hémicycle pour débattre de la
situation de ces travailleurs qui se
dégradent loi avenir professionnel et
loi mobilité dont les sharks facultative
ont été censurés suite à notre saisine
du conseil constitutionnel
notre proposition sur les coopératives
l'intéressante pepel communiste porté
par pascal savoldelli sans compter le
rappeur de nos collègues dont frédéric
puisard cette proposition a été déposée
le 4 mars dernier en hommage à la
décision historique de la cour de
cassation du 4 mars 2020 et requalifier
un chauffeur hubert en salariés et en
dénonçant avec force l'indépendance
fictive des travailleurs de plates
formes de travail
notre état de droit fonctionne malgré
vos multiples tentatives de le
contourner depuis 2010 est en souhaitant
continuellement davantage protéger les
plates formes plutôt que les
travailleurs des plates formes
auxquelles elles font appel
preuve en est votre ordonnance sur le
dialogue social du vin
en avril désavouant le rapport foin que
vous aviez pourtant commandé en ce qu'il
rejetait l'idée d'un nouveau statut que
voulue suggériez avec cette ordonnance
ou persévérer dans leurs démarches
visant à contourner le droit du travail
en créant de facto un nouveau sous
statut de travailleur entre salariat et
indépendance qui institutionnalisera le
travail pauvre sans garantie le revenu
et avec une protection sociale low cost
vous centrée sur les seuls livreur est
chauffeur de vtc est alors créé un
système de représentation propre mais il
ya un problème constitutionnel qui a été
pointée par la mission froid un conseil
d'état et oui dès lors que des
entreprises
les auto-entrepreneurs par exemple
s'entend donc aux dépens de leurs
donneurs d'ordre dans le droit de la
concurrence cela s'appelle une entente
un cartel c'est illégal
vous continuez de tergiverser alors que
la situation des uv risée se dégrade et
s'aggrave rhumel mort le 4 mai à la
porte de la chapelle
chailly à sotteville les rouen le 6 tous
deux percuté par des véhicules des sans
papiers en grève pour dénoncer les
effroyables conditions de sous traitants
chez frichti l'été dernier zola et hugo
n'aurait pu imaginer un tel retour aux
tâches renage dans leurs pires
cauchemars mais nous ne refusons ni le
progrès ni la réalité
la technologie numérique a du bon et
nous l'utilisons tous d'octo libre
blaquart le bon coin sont de parfaits
exemples de plates formes qui ne posent
pas les problèmes et questions des
plateformes de travail
le cocktail de l'ubs et risation
contient deux ingrédients explosifs
le dévoiement du statut
d'auto-entrepreneur que vous avez
dénoncé madame puisant dans votre
intérêt sans rapport sur les plateformes
et le management par l'algorithme cette
boîte noire sourde et aveugle du
management 2.0
protégé par le secret de fabrication ces
2 ingrédients sont mis en réaction dans
un contexte très favorable
l'aspiration général a plu autonomie
dans le travail confondus
dans cette fable de l'indépendance que
vous êtes nombreux à entretenir et la
situation permanente de la crise de
l'emploi
je vais illustrer les trois articles de
ce texte par trois exemples de
véritables travailleurs qui permet de
démasquer ce cheval de troie contre
notre modèle social
car hui les quelques dizaines de
milliers de livres heures et chauffeur
vtc sont l'arbre qui cache la forêt
premier exemple article reims alexandre
32 ans était celle meurt pas loin d'ici
par l'entremise de la prade plateforme
extra kadabra il est devenu
auto-entrepreneur début 2020 et pour le
même employeur
s'ils gagnaient un peu plus les premiers
mois le confinement l'a laissé sans
travail ni revenu faut de cotisation et
n'entrant pas dans les critères du fonds
de soutien
il est dans la misère a entamé une
procédure pour être qualifié en salariés
il en a pour plusieurs années de
procédures judiciaires pour peut-être
aboutir
c'est pour ces travailleurs abusé que
nous proposons l'article 1
une procédure de requalification par
action de groupe pour qu'un seul avocat
puis s'occuper de tout un ensemble de
contrats dupliquer est identique est
donc qualifié massivement et clarifier
le paysage de ces plateformes de travail
et si vous vous inquiétez sur les
risques de chômage soyez rassurés just
hits numéro trois du secteur de la
livraison en france embauche des
livreurs en cdi
elle fait la preuve de son modèle dans
d'autres pays deuxième exemple à
l'article de l'or 29 ans est infirmière
dans un hôpital à nancy auto
entrepreneuse recruté par la plateforme
met dife
lâche rien à voir avec l'infirmière
libérale que vous connaissez qui passent
de maison en maison
cherchant sa clientèle et organisant son
emploi du temps
elle travaille dans un hôpital
totalement subordonnée
c'est pour leurs essais indépendants
fictif que nous proposons à l'article 2
d'inverser la charge de la preuve est de
présumer salariés les travailleurs de
plateformes
bah oui aux plateformes d'aller en
justice si elle veut prouver que ces
travailleurs ont les caractéristiques
d'une indépendance réelle dans l'âme
nominés ce gouvernement espagnol vient
de la trique et au mois d'avril
article 3 brahim 37 ans chauffeur de vtc
chez hubert revendiquer ses droits et à
la et appeler à l'action ses collègues
en décembre 2019
il a été déconnecté sans autre forme de
procès ni possibilité de recours avec
l'article 3 nous voulons permettre aux
prud'hommes
appuyé par des experts de rendre
l'algorithme plus transparent pour mieux
le réguler éviter des situations telles
que les responsabilités humaines
resterait caché par cette boîte noire
protégés par le secret de fabrication
voilà chers collègues l'enjeu de cette
séance
si nous perdons ce combat sociétale ce
cheval de troie que notre gouvernement
incertain stimulent irait beaucoup plus
loin
je tiens à souligner ici le puissant
lobbying de la plateforme
hubert au plus profond de nos
institutions républicaines car leur vrai
combat c'est de ne plus vouloir payer
les temps d'attentes des travailleurs
leur modèle économique ne le permettrait
pas s'il gagne ce sont des secteurs
entiers qui seront un jour réduit au
talonnage
vous voyez déjà la situation sur les
aides à domicile qui ne peuvent gagner
le smic mensuel étant à peine défrayer
entre deux clients alors oui en baissant
encore le coût du travail
nous pourrions nous offrir bien des
services nouveaux et créateur d'emplois
mais le
jeu en vaut-il la chandelle s'il conduit
à produire en masse des travailleurs
pauvres
nous affirmons que non nous voulons de
ce modèle ni pour nous ni pour nos
enfants
mes chers collègues vous allez
clairement par ce court texte choisir
votre camp celui que vous propose notre
ministre d'aller mettre au vert c'est
vers cette société du cyber précariat et
d'un sous statut et donc de protéger les
plates formes plutôt que les
travailleurs de plateformes ou celui
d'une juste régulation l'algorithme du
travail décent au 21ème siècle de la
justice et du progrès humain
merci merci la parole est maintenant
monsieur jean luc fichet rapporteur de
la commission des affaires sociales pour
10 minutes vous avez la parole cher
collègue madame la ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
la proposition de loi déposée par notre
collègue olivier jacquin et les membres
du groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains vise à mieux protéger les
travailleurs des plateformes numériques
en mettant à leur disposition des outils
destinée à rééquilibrer le rapport de
force devant les juridictions
parce qu'ils demandent leur
requalification en salariés en effet
l'apparition et le développement rapide
d'entreprises ayant pour objet la mise
en relation par des outils numériques de
consommateurs et de clients avec une
multitude de travailleurs supposément
indépendant constitue l'une des
évolutions récentes et plus marquantes
les plus inquiétantes du marché du
travail
cette numérisation est particulièrement
visible dans les secteurs de voitures de
transport et chauffeurs et de la
livraison à domicile de denrées ou de
reports mais tend à s'étendre un nombre
croissant d'activités comme les serveurs
ou les avocats
ce phénomène constitue une remise en
question frontale de notre modèle social
en permettant un retour insidieux du
tonnage du
neuvième siècle que la construction
progressive du droit du travail avait
justement cherché à éradiquer la
dégradation de la situation de l'emploi
sam est en effet assez plate forme ne
disposer d' une main d'oeuvre nombreuse
était prête à accepter des conditions de
travail indignes une grande précarité et
des rémunérations souvent dérisoires
certains autres offerts au départ des
conditions très émue l'actrice suscitant
un grand engouement
et au fur et à mesure de leur
développement les conditions d'emploi
sur les plates formes se sont dégradées
les profits les profils des travailleurs
concernés on est également évolué
aujourd'hui bien souvent des plateformes
exploitent la détresse des migrants en
situation irrégulière est prêt à
accepter n'importe quoi à n'importe
quelles conditions ces travailleurs sont
contraints pour travailler sur les
plates formes de recourir un statut
d'indépendant que leur faible
rémunération ne leur permettent
généralement pas d'assumer du fait de
leur statut ils ne bénéficient pas des
dispositions du code du travail
relatives notamment au salaire minimum
au repos aux congés payés ou encore
l'encadrement de la rupture de la
relation de travail
on voit donc bien leur culte
constitution de travail qui consiste à
contourner les protections offertes par
notre modèle social aux salariés pour
tant qu'indépendant cet arrière
bénéficie en outre d'une protection
sociale lacunaire ainsi ne sont pas
couverts au titre de l'assurance chômage
alors que leurs activités par nature est
un mythe haute et que les plateformes
peu unilatérale unilatéralement y mettre
un terme
ils ne sont pas non plus couverts par la
branche accidents du travail et des
maladies professionnelles
alors que leur activité n'est
dans le cas des livreurs ou des
chauffeurs de vtc particulièrement
risquée et qu'un accident peut réduire à
néant notre capacité à travailler ils ne
bénéficient pas davantage de la
généralisation de la couverture maladie
complémentaire obligatoirement proposé
par les employeurs à leurs salariés
depuis la loi de sécurisation de
l'emploi de 2013 enfin les travailleurs
concernés généralement jeunes
méconnaissent souvent les enjeux liés à
la retraite en la cotisation minimale
permettant de valider trois trimestres
par an au titre de l'assurance
vieillesse n'est pas applicable aux
micro-entrepreneurs régime souvent
choisies par les livreurs en raison de
sa simplicité
s'il recourt statut d'indépendant
imposés par certaines plateformes aux
travailleurs quel emploi est
problématique
il est également abusif en effet les
conditions dans lesquelles ces
travailleurs exercent leur activité
s'apparente bien souvent en fait un
travail salarié
je rappelle qu'en l'état actuel du droit
le choix des parties de se placer dans
le cas d'une relation commerciale entre
un client et un prestataire ne s'impose
pas aux juges la qualification de
contrat de travail étant d'ordre public
le conseil de prud'hommes s'il est saisi
peut ainsi requalifiés une relation de
travail indépendant en contrat de
travail salarié s'il constate qu'il
existe dans les faits une relation de
subordination
cette possibilité existe même lorsque la
loi reconnaît une présomption de travail
indépendant comme c'est le cas pour les
micro entrepreneurs ils les dirigeants
d'entreprise unipersonnelle le
travailleur ainsi qualifiés à leur droit
au versement de rappel de salaire et à
l'indemnisation des préjudices subis
y compris au titre de la rupture abusive
de son contrat de travail le cas échéant
au cours de la période récente
deux arrêts fondateur de la cour de
cassation ont affirmé que la situation
dans laquelle croyait des livreurs de
l'ancienne plateforme de livraison take
it easy ou des chauffeurs de vtc de la
société hubert devait être regardée
comme constitutive d'une indépendance
fictive et donc comme une relation de
travail salarié de nombreuses demandes
france change sont actuellement en cours
d'examen par les conseils de prud'hommes
et des cours d'appel
toutefois ces procédures sont longues et
coûteuses pour des travailleurs en
situation de vulnérabilité en août
ressort encore hasardeuse malgré les
décisions qui me semble pourtant claire
de la cour de cassation
plusieurs qu'on appelle ont ainsi refusé
de requalifier les travailleurs de
plateforme au cours des derniers mois
sur la base d' analyse au cas par cas la
situation actuelle est donc porteuse
d'une insécurité juridique dont on ne
peut pas se satisfaire la combustion de
loi déposée par notre collègue olivier
jacquin vise à mettre fin aux ambiguïtés
qui laisse prospérer cette situation il
semble
premièrement nécessaire des facilités
avec son endroit pour les travailleurs
franchement indépendante
c'est l'objet de l'article 1er qui nomme
en créant une procédure d'action du
groupe au bénéfice des travailleurs
subissant un préjudice du fait du
recours un statut fictif d'indépendance
il s'agit de permettre à la multitude
des travailleurs placé dans la même
situation vis-à-vis des plateformes de
faire ensemble valoir leurs droits de
manière plus efficace
je rappelle que l'action de groupe
introduite dans le droit français par la
loi à mon 2014 vis à vis à renforcer la
protection des droits des citoyens en
permettant à plusieurs justiciables
victimes d'un même préjudice de se
regrouper pour agir en justice
des actions du goût sont possibles dans
le domaine de la consommation de la
santé ou encore en matière de
discrimination du travail
cette nouvelle action du groupe pour et
elle est exercée par une organisation
syndicale par une association
intervenant dans le domaine de la
défense les travailleurs indépendants
elle serait introduite devant le
tribunal judiciaire sans doute le mieux
armé que le conseil des prud'hommes pour
traiter des dossiers massif une fois que
le juge aurait reconnu l'existence du
préjudice et définit les profils des
victimes tous les travailleurs concernés
pourraient se joindre à l'action de
groupe les modifier d'une indemnisation
sans avoir besoin d'entreprendre une
longue et coûteuse actions individuelles
le rapport de force entre les
travailleurs demandent aux une
requalification et la plateforme junte
ainsi rééquilibrer
naturellement cette action ne vous
préfecture et par les actions
individuelles que les travailleurs
pourraient vouloir mener auprès du
conseil de prud'hommes s'il avait à
faire valoir une droit un droit ou une
situation qui lance son propre et
convient par ailleurs par ailleurs de
clarifier le droit face de mettre fin à
l'incertitude qui entoure les actions de
leurs qualifications
le législateur s'est jusqu'à présent
refusé à reconnaître le circuit le
salarié ou travailleur des plateformes
ou alors étendre les garanties dont
bénéficient les salariés comme il l'a
fait pour d'autres catégories de
travailleurs atypiques tels que les
journalistes les mannequins ou les vrp
au contraire les dernières évolutions
législatives survenus depuis les
premiers jalons posés par la loi elles
comrie de 2016 quelques la loi
d'orientation des mobilités du 24
décembre 2019 ou l' ordonnance du 21
avril 21 relative aux modalités de
représentation des travailleurs de
plateformes ont visé à conforter sans
l'affirmer définitivement d'un statut
d'indépendant se bornant imposer
certaines obligations de financement des
avantages sociaux de transparence ou le
dialogue social aux plateformes
dans ce contexte l'article 2
de la proposition de loi tend à abroger
les dispositions actuelles le voyant une
présomption de travail indépendant et
alors substitué une présomption de
salariat
cette présomption ne serait pas
irréfragable mais il appartiendrait à la
plateforme de démontrer l'absence de
lien de subordination
il s'agit donc d'inverser la charge de
la preuve au bénéfice d'un parti qui
dispose de moins de moyens c'est à dire
du travailleur ce dispositif de chez
limite pas aux performances aux
plateformes dont on devait essayer de
livraison dont on observe déjà des
ravages mais pourrait s'appliquer à
toute forme de relations de travail dans
lesquelles un algorithme intervient
enfin la demande de requalification et
en règle générale examiné par les
prud'hommes
il convient de donner à cet instant sa
capacité d'apprécier la réalité des
conditions de travail étant une
plateforme cette fin article 3 permet au
conseil des prud'hommes d'exiger la
production des algorithmes utilisés par
les plateformes
parce que la protection des droits des
travailleurs et en juin surtout l'apport
principal de cet article est de prévoir
la possibilité pour le juge de recourir
à un expert afin de les analyser
voilà j'arrive cette option de monsieur
le rapporteur avait l'âge ne dépasse
jusqu'à conclusion si c'est une phrase
donc je regrette donc la commission des
affaires sociales et reçu cette
proposition
c'est ce point que nos débats cet après
midi permettront de faire évoluer les
positions de ces déçus qui au sein de
cette assemblée demeurent frileux face à
ce geste politique qui me semble
nécessaire
merci
la parole est maintenant à madame
elisabeth bornes ministre du travail de
l'emploi et de l'insertion
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
je voudrais tout d'abord remercier le
groupe socialistes écologistes et
républicains notamment monsieur le
sénateur jacques un monsieur les
sénateurs montaugé et madame la
sénatrice lubin de nous donner
l'occasion de débattre des plateformes
les plateformes numériques se sont
fortement développées en france comme
partout dans le monde et ont permis de
créer de nouveaux gisements d'emplois
certaines ne pose d'ailleurs pas de
difficulté en ce qu'elle respecte le
modèle d'un réel travail indépendant
elle constitue pour beaucoup de
nouvelles opportunités professionnelles
comme voie d'accès rapide à la vie
active ou comme véritable choix de vie
pour celles et ceux qui veulent échapper
aux contraintes du salariat avec ses
horaires fixes et sa hiérarchie mais
dans le même temps
l'émergence de ces nouvelles formes
d'emploi interroge notre modèle social
en exposant ses travailleurs un statut
précaire et à une protection sociale
insuffisante
je partage le constat avec les auteurs
de la proposition de loi que les
relations contractuelles entre les
travailleurs indépendants et plateformes
sont encore trop souvent déséquilibrée
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement a choisi d'accompagner le
développement des plates formes de mise
en relation tout en veillant à mieux
protéger les travailleurs qui recourent
nous voulons à la fois préserver
l'indépendance de ces travailleurs et
bâtir des droits individuels et
collectifs ainsi qu'une protection
sociale adapté
alors vous voyez monsieur le sénateur
jacques 1 ce n'est pas parce que nous ne
prenons pas le même chemin qu'il faut
caricaturer la position du gouvernement
et vous le savez très bien que je suis
aussi déterminé que vous
à donner des droits à ces travailleurs
et je peux également vous indiquer que
j'ai mobilisé les services du ministère
du travail en particulier l'inspection
du travail pour identifier les fraudes
et effectivement sanctionnés les
situations dans lesquelles les
travailleurs ne sont pas réellement
indépendants ou les cas aussi on a des
sous traitants ce qui expose des
personnes en situation dérive
irrégulière à des conditions de travail
indignes
donc on peut en ont peut échanger sur
ces sujets sans caricaturer les
positions moi je suis convaincu que la
régulation sociale de ce secteur passe
par la structuration d'un dialogue
social entre les plateformes et les
représentants légitimes des travailleurs
indépendants c'est le développement d'un
thé tête d'un tel dialogue qui permettra
d'assurer un meilleur équilibre des
relations commerciales et une
rémunération adaptée aux nouvelles
formes de couleurs d'emplois qu'elles
introduisent nous voulons mettre ces
travailleurs en situation à travers la
négociation collective de définir les
solutions les plus adaptées à un univers
du travail spécifique est encore en
pleine évolution
cette proposition de loi ne nous semble
pas atteindre les objectifs qu'elle vise
elle pourrait même générer une grande
insécurité juridique
tout d'abord l'article 1 élargi l'action
de groupe aux travailleurs qui
subiraient des préjudices liés à un
statut d'indépendant présumés fictifs
il ouvre également la possibilité de
reconnaître la qualité de salarié en
confiant cette action au tribunal
judiciaire la proposition de loi mais
connaît la compétence des juridictions
prud'homales qui seuls peuvent se
prononcer sur la requalification d'une
relation commerciale en salariat par
ailleurs cette action de groupe ne prend
pas en compte le nouveau régime instauré
par l' ordonnance relative à la
représentation des travailleurs des
plateforme sur laquelle je reviendrai
surtout rien ne s'oppose aujourd'hui au
traitement par les conseils des
prud'hommes de plusieurs demande de
requalification exercer simultanément
par plusieurs travailleurs indépendants
les mécanismes existent déjà
ensuite l'article 2
un sport dans le code du travail une
présomption de salariat dès lors que les
deux tiers du revenu professionnel sont
issus de l'exploitation d'un algorithme
en supprimant la présomption de travail
indépendant définit aujourd'hui dans le
code du travail
cet article entraîna entraînera des
effets de bord massif préjudiciable à
l'ensemble des indépendants artisans
commerçants et professions libérales
en effet les articles du code du travail
aux qualifs se réfère concerne
l'ensemble des travailleurs indépendants
soit un statut bien plus large que les
seuls travailleurs des plateformes
or un artisan indépendant ne connaît pas
les mêmes problématiques qu'un chauffeur
vtc travaillant pour une plateforme la
réponse apportée ne peut pas être
uniforme
par ailleurs ni le seuil de rémunération
ni l'utilisation d'un algorithme ne
peuvent constituer un critère suffisant
pour qualifier une relation de salariat
l'élément essentiel qui détermine
l'existence d'un contrat de travail
c'est le lien de subordination la part
de rémunération ici d'une plateforme une
gestion algorithmiques sont des indices
de cette subordination mais ne peuvent
emporter à eux seuls la preuve d'une
subordination surtout quelles que soient
les présomptions que législateur
prévoira le juge conservera toujours la
possibilité d'apprécier la situation en
fonction des conditions concrètes
d'exercice de l'activité
enfin l'article droit donne la
possibilité au conseil des prud'hommes
d'ordonner aux plateformes de produire
la preuve que l'algorithme n'est pas au
centre de la relation contractuelle
là encore ce sont les caractéristiques
concrète de l'activité qui permettent la
qualification d'une situation de travail
comme relevant du salariat ou de
l'indépendance l'important n'est pas
tant l'algorithme mais ce qu'il peut
éventuellement produire en termes de
subordination une telle rédaction appel
l'obligation pour les plateformes
d'apporter une preuve négatif ce qui en
droit est toujours très complexe quand
ça n'est pas tout simplement impossible
malgré des intentions que je partage
largement et vous le savez très bien
monsieur le sénateur jacques 1 comme
celle de protéger les travailleurs
indépendants des plateformes et de
lutter contre l'indépendance fictive la
rédaction de ces trois articles
pose des difficultés juridiques elle
peut rendre leur disposition non
seulement inopérante mais également
préjudiciable à tous les autres
indépendants le gouvernement a opté
depuis déjà plusieurs années pour une
autre stratégie celle de la
structuration d'un dialogue social
garantissant des conditions de
l'indépendance réelle
notre objectif est en effet d'organiser
le dialogue social au sein du secteur
pour permettre à ces travailleurs d'être
représentés et de pouvoir mieux défendre
leurs intérêts face aux plateformes et
ces sujets me tiennent à coeur
je tiens à saluer le travail conjoint
mené avec le sénateur jacques 1 au
moment de la loi d'orientation des
mobilités que j'ai porté en tant que
ministre des transports cette toit a
déjà permis d'instaurer de nouvelles
garanties pour les travailleurs par
exemple les plateformes sont désormais
tenus de communiquer avant chaque
prestation la distance couverte et le
prix minimal garanti d'une course
les travailleurs peuvent quant à eux de
choisir librement leurs plages
d'horaires d'activité y compris de
déconnexion et d'inactivité et ils
peuvent désormais refuser une prestation
sans que cela n'occasionne une
quelconque pénalité sur la base d'une
habilitation issue de cette loi nous
avons adopté une ordonnance le 21 avril
dernier qui pose les premières briques
d'un dialogue social dans ce secteur
elle permet aux travailleurs des
plateformes d'avoir accès à une
représentation
ces résultats nous avons obtenu en
créant les conditions d'une concertation
apaisé et approfondies en inscrivant le
sujet à l'agenda social dès juillet et
en confiant des missions successives à
des experts cette ordonnance permettra
de structurer le dialogue social social
au sein des deux secteurs les plus
significatifs celui des activités de
conduite d'une veillée une voiture de
transport avec chauffeur vtc et celui
des activités de livraison de
marchandises à domicile qui ensemble
représentent près de cent mille
travailleurs indépendants concrètement
pour chacun de ces deux secteurs une
élection nationale à tour unique et par
vote électronique sera organisé au
printemps 2022
elle permettra aux travailleurs
indépendants chauffeur devait cdtc ou
livres
à vélo d'élire les organisations qui les
représenteront et de désigner leurs
représentants lors du premier scrutin
pourront être reconnues représentatives
les organisations recueillant au moins
5% des suffrages exprimés
les représentants désignés par les
organisations représentatives
bénéficieront de garanties particulières
afin de les protéger contre tout risque
de discrimination du fait de leur mandat
il s'agit d'un premier pas inédit vers
une meilleure régulation sociale des
plates formes en particulier la rupture
du contrat liant l'un de ses
représentants à une plateforme sera
soumise à autorisation administrative
préalable ses représentants
bénéficieront par ailleurs d'une
indemnisation pour le temps consacré
leur mandat et d'un droit à la formation
au dialogue social afin d'avoir les
outils et connaissances nécessaires à
l'exercice d'un mandat syndical
en parallèle l ordonnance prévoit la
création de l'autorité de deux des
relations des plates formes d'emploi
établissement public dédié à la
régulation des relations sociales entre
plateformes et travailleurs indépendants
qui recourent cette nouvelle autorité
opérationnel en septembre 2021 sera pour
l'essentiel une instance de facilitation
du dialogue social chargé de
l'organisation des élections
professionnelles et du suivi des
concertations des décrets d'application
de l'ordonnancé seront publiés au cours
du mois de juin et mission de
préfiguration sera lancée dans les tout
prochains jours
l'objectif est d'initier le travail
d'organisation des élections dans la
foulée de la mise en place de l'arpp
cette ordonnance tout comme la mission
qui sera lancée constituent les
premières pierres d'un dialogue social
qui permettra de mieux comprendre les
attentes des deux parties est d'aboutir
à des solutions équilibrées
vous le voyez le gouvernement et la
majorité présidentielle ont obtenu des
avancées majeures en termes de
représentation des travailleurs des
plateformes
au cours de ces travaux nous avons par
ailleurs toujours veillé à ne pas
fragiliser ce modèle économique fondé
sur l'indépendance et qui pourvoit à
l'actif de l'activité à quelques cents
mille travailler
nous allons poursuivre ce chantier de la
structuration du dialogue social des
travailleurs des plateformes et en
ouvrir d'autres comme celui de la
protection sociale
tout d'abord nous proposerons
prochainement des dispositions
complémentaires à celles prévues à
l'ordonnancé du 21 avril au regard des
préconisations issues de la mission
coordonnée par bruno mettling
ainsi nous souhaitons compléter cette
première étape essentielle de
structuration du dialogue social par des
dispositions législatives qui
préciseront les mondes modalités de
représentation des plates formes elles
mêmes les règles relatives à la
négociation collective entre plateformes
et représentants de travailleurs
indépendants qui recourent dans un
deuxième temps nous ouvrirons des
concertations sur un nombre un certain
nombre de nouveaux sujets comme par
exemple la protection sociale de ces
travailleurs je peux d'ores et déjà vous
dire que nous nous engageons à améliorer
la protection de ces travailleurs en cas
d'accident du travail ou de maladies
professionnelles
je pense avant tout aux livreurs à vélo
qui méritent une protection sociale à la
hauteur des risques encourus dans un
secteur éminemment accidentogène en
parallèle nous travaillerons avec la
commission européenne pour faire évoluer
le droit de la concurrence et permettre
aux plateformes et aux travailleurs
indépendants de négocier des accords
cette possibilité ouvrira la voie à une
négociation sur le calcul d'un revenu
minimum corrélée à l'activité et donc à
une convergence sociale vers le haut en
europe
je pense que nous pouvons tous nous
retrouver sur cette ambition de
renforcer notre modèle social tout en
assurant notre relance et notre
prospérité économique
c'est la voie équilibrée que nous
traçons mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
la priorité doit être selon nous
d'améliorer la protection sociale des
travailleurs des plateformes sans
chercher nécessairement aller
requalifier en salariés ce que beaucoup
ne souhaitent pas et pour inventer une
protection sociale adapté à la nature
particulière de ce secteur
nous voulons qu'elles émergent des
travailleurs eux mêmes dans le dialogue
social et la concertation
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
attend attachons avant tout à structurer
des conditions de la représentativité et
de la négociation collective
au sein du secteur des plateformes c'est
la voie que nous suivons pour permettre
à ses activités économies de se
développer et à ses travailleurs de
s'insérer sur le marché du travail tout
en respectant le cadre d'une
indépendance réelle pour toutes les
raisons que je viens d'évoquer le
gouvernement n'est donc pas favorable
aux dispositions de cette proposition de
loi je remercie merci madame la ministre
nous allons entamer la discussion
générale avec les orateurs des groupes
je rappelle le groupe socialiste que
pour l'ensemble de cette discussion
générale comme pour le débat sur les
articles qui suivent il dispose encore
précisément d'une heure pas plus dans la
suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur michel canevet
pour le groupe union centriste pour six
minutes
[Applaudissements]
ce le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues le groupe de
l'union centriste tient d'abord à saluer
l'initiative prise par olivier jacquin
et les membres du groupe socialiste de
mettre sur le débat en séance publique
au sénat
cette question de l'emploi des
travailleurs des plateformes numériques
alors c'est un sujet important le sénat
a déjà eu l'occasion de s'en saisir
pascal savoldelli et les membres du
groupe communiste ont déjà eu l'occasion
de présenter un texte à ce sujet la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat sand est également saisi puisqu'un
rapport de michel forissier de notre
collègue catherine fournier puis de fait
depuis ça ici présentes a pu formuler un
certain nombre de propositions après
avoir analysé la situation et puis la
délégation sénatoriale aux entreprises
présidée par serge barbarie ici présent
est en train de travailler actuellement
sur les nouveaux modes de management et
les nouvelles formes d'emploi et devrait
aussi pouvoir formuler très
prochainement des des propositions en ce
sens c'est dire que le sénat est
complètement investis madame la ministre
sur cette question qui est importante
alors le groupe de l'union centriste il
est particulièrement attaché à la libre
entreprise et fait de pouvoir
véritablement entreprendre dans notre
pays il y a entre trois millions et demi
et 4 millions d' indépendants dans notre
pays qui en complément des salariés
forment l'ensemble des actifs de la
france nous estimons que c'est
indépendants sont une force importante
pour notre pays pour la dynamique
économique d'autres pays et qu'il ne
faudrait pas que celles-ci soient
réduites par des législations des
réglementations qui soit beaucoup trop
complexe donc il faut que l'on veille
dans tout ce que l'on fait à à ce que on
n'altère pas le principe de la libre
entreprise et que la dynamique puisse
continuer dans notre pays alors la
dynamique
on le voit bien elle s'exprime notamment
par la question du numérique du
développement du numérique important qui
offre de nouvelles potentialités
d'activité et donc d'emplois cela fait
déjà pas mal de temps que nous
connaissons les chauffeurs de véhicules
de type hubert on a parle de l'ubs
irisation bien souvent il n'ya pas que
cela puisque la situation pandémique que
nous venons de connaître à la fois je
dirais affirmé accru la maturité
digitales des entreprises dans notre
pays et ça c'est un bien il y a eu un
saut digital qui est vraiment conséquent
qui a été menée pendant cette période
pandémique mais elle a vu aussi se
développer de nouvelles formes de
services à la population
il suffit pour cela de se rendre dans
les rues le soir pour voir l'ensemble
des livreurs avaient loué un vélomoteur
ou autres modes de transport pouvoir
aller chez les clients chez les usagers
qui sont de plus en plus nombreux
peut-être que les contraintes de
circulation font que ces métiers se sont
largement développées y occuper
l'actualité
en tout état de cause c'est une nouvelle
forme de travail qui est important alors
à partir de de ce constat à la fois de
la libre entreprise à la fois de du
développement du numérique il faut se
poser la question de savoir comment
doit-on organiser cela puisque un
certain nombre de difficultés ont été
identifiés beaucoup de débats en lieu
sûr cette question du salariat et du
type de contrat par lequel doivent être
régies ses relations entre les acteurs
de l'ensemble de ce commerce ou de ses
activités liées au numérique
alors pour notre part disons le et je
tiens à la ferme et aux rapporteurs
nous ne suivrons pas tout à fait ses
conclusions sur ce sujet le débat a déjà
eu lieu en commission des affaires
sociales mais il nous semble important
de conserver la dynamique de
développement de ses activités
il nous semble aussi je crois important
de faire en sorte que les initiatives
qui ont déjà été prises à cet égard
puisse montrer leurs résultats et vous
venez d'évoquer madame la ministre
l'ordonance qui a été prise après
différentes missions du 21 avril dernier
je souhaitais vous interroger sur les
modalités de mise en oeuvre notamment
pour l'art peut mais vous venez à
l'instant d'y répondre et nous nous
réjouissons que des
le mois prochain les premiers décrets
pourront être pris pour pouvoir mettre
en oeuvre l'ensemble du dispositif et
que dès lors la peut soit effectivement
opérationnel avant la fin de l'année et
que ses relations puissent se mettre en
place pour enfin que l'organisation du
scrutin puisse se mettre en place au
plus tôt parce que au niveau du groupe
de l'union centriste nous avons la
conviction que c'est effectivement par
le dialogue social que nous arriverons à
avancer il faut qu'il y ait d'un certain
nombre de dispositions qu'ils soient
prises en direction des indépendants on
sait que la couverture accidents du
travail est quelque chose d'important
que des complémentaires santé sont aussi
nécessaires
donc on voit bien qu'il y a à faire
évoluer ce statut d indépendant le
gouvernement a déjà lancé quelques
initiatives pour ce qui concerne la
couverture dit chômage en quelque sorte
mais on n'est pas allé assez loin donc
nous attendons au niveau du groupe de
l'union centriste que l'on puisse
avancer sur ce statut d indépendant donc
le groupe de l'union centriste ne votera
pas ce texte en l'état
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur serge babary
président de la délégation aux
entreprises pour le goff les
républicains pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
affaires sociales sur le rapporteur nous
savons tous la plateforme isation de
notre société ne fait que commencer
elle recouvre une réalité très divers le
monde des plateformes englobant
plusieurs secteurs et non des moindres
avec en particulier celui de la mobilité
vtc livraison à domicile celui des
services à la personne et celui des
services aux entreprises l'actualité est
rendu particulièrement visibles les
livreurs à domicile dont le nombre a
explosé avec la crise sanitaire et
l'évolution des modes de consommation
leur exposition au risque a alerté et
alimenter le débat sur leur fragilité
économique
le sénat s'est saisie du problème en
2020 avec le rapport de la commission
des affaires sociales ainsi qu'une
proposition de loi du groupe crc elle
est aujourd'hui avec sa proposition de
loi déposée par des collègues des
groupes socialistes
en outre la délégation d'entreprises a
lancé en décembre 2020 une mission
d'information sur les nouveaux modes de
travail et de management
elle travaille via les plateformes fait
bien sûr partie de son champ de
réflexion
les questions sont multiples et la lite
est délicate à appréhender par le
législateur il nous faut être vigilant à
plusieurs titres il nous faut veiller à
la situation des travailleurs concernés
un certain nombre risque la
précarisation financière et sociale
mais la majorité tiennent à
l'indépendance que leur permet leur
statut et la flexibilité leur activité
alors se pose bien sûr la question
cruciale comment trouver le juste
équilibre entre indépendance et
dépendances imposé via les algorithmes
des plateformes romandie
comment déterminer le caractère réel ou
fictif de cette indépendance autrement
qu'au cas par cas
il nous faut par ailleurs veiller à ne
pas entraver le dynamisme de ses
entreprises activités permises par les
technologies actuelles plébiscité par
les consommateurs et créatrice d'emplois
comment conjuguer ces trois impératifs
répondre à cette demande croissante
rééquilibrer quand nécessaire
l'asymétrie des relations de travail et
permettent le développement d'un modèle
économique viable
certains défendent la création d'un
statut intermédiaire entre celui de
salarié et celui d'indépendant
mais cela viendrait encore complexifier
le paysage juridique cette option
d'ailleurs été écarté suite au rapport
froid la proposition de loi jacquin
s'attaque à de vraies questions
les solutions défendu ne nous parlent
cependant pas adéquat
outre qu'elles ne répondent pas aux
souhaits d'une majorité des travailleurs
concernés elle j'ignore la question
cruciale de la viabilité économique et
des activités concernées dans un tel cas
suite aux auditions conduites à la fois
par la commission des affaires sociales
et par notre délégation d'entreprises
je ressors convaincu que le
rééquilibrage des relations de travail
et la défense des droits des
travailleurs
les plateformes doit passer avant tout
par la négociation collective afin de
prendre en compte les spécificités de
chaque secteur
de ce point de vue la récente ordonnance
sur la représentation de ces
travailleurs devra s'accompagner des
possibles d'un dialogue social nourri et
équilibrée en outre la problématique ne
paraît plus large et plus anciennes
il est urgent de réduire voire supprimer
les disparités qui demeurent entre les
trois ennemis et 4 millions de
travailleurs indépendants et les
salariés disposant de revenus
équivalents il ya là le véritable
inéquité la question des travailleurs
des plateformes n'en est qu'une des
variantes mais une des plus criantes
le haut conseil du financement de la
protection sociale l'a d'ailleurs
souligné dans son rapport de septembre
2001 sur la protection sociale des
travailleurs indépendants et son
financement
je cite les collaborateurs des
plateformes notamment chez eux et jacent
au secteur de la mobilité souvent micro
entrepreneurs
compte parmi les non salariés les plus
précaires en termes de couverture
sociale et de revenus dégagés
le haut conseil a prôné la clarification
des règles de rattachement et
l'amélioration de l'équité du
prélèvement social
il a composé un new deal pour la
protection sociale des travailleurs
indépendants ce pacte devant ce site
reposer sur un système de prélèvement
revue des droits renforcés et un
équilibre entre droits et devoirs des
non-salariés réexaminée et justement
réaffirmé le point de vue le plan en
faveur des indépendants annoncé par le
ministre à la crise et pour fin avril
est toujours en attente
vous l'avez compris je ne suis pas
favorable à l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi de même de mes
collègues du groupe l'est républicain
en revanche nous restons très vigilants
sur ces questions et veilleront à ce que
l'équilibré entre les droits et
obligations de chacun soit atteint je
vous remercie
maintenant à notre collègue pierre jan
vertonghen pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
l'essor des plateformes a bouleversé
notre quotidien a bouleversé le monde du
travail qui reposait jusque alors sur un
ensemble de règles de droit et le
garantis cette nouvelle forme de travail
indépendant est une source de débouchés
pour plus de deux cent mille personnes
en france mais pose ça a été évoqué de
nombreux questionnements juridique la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans la lignée de
la récente décision de la cour de
cassation de mars dernier selon laquelle
une relation commerciale entre un
chauffeur de vtc et la fameuse
plateforme numérique
uber pouvait être requalifié en contrat
de travail
en effet la présomption de non salariés
du travailleur indépendant peut être
renversé dès lors qu'un lien de
subordination juridique était établie
entre l'auto entrepreneur et des
donneurs d'ordre dans le cas d'une plate
forme d'une plateforme de vtc ou de
livraison à vélo l'impossibilité pour le
travailleur d'organiser librement son
activité de recherche et sa clientèle ou
l'existence d'un pouvoir de sanction ou
des montres
dans cette situation le caractère fictif
du statut de travailleur indépendant à
partir de cette jurisprudence le texte
propose d'étendre travailleurs du
numérique la procédure d'action de
groupe issu de la loi monde 2014 et
apica est applicable pardon en matière
de droit de la consommation notamment
d'autre part l'auteur propose de
supprimer la présomption de non
salariales lorsque les trois quarts des
revenus reposent sur l'exploitation d'un
algorithme
enfin l'article 3 prévoit en cas de
recours pour re qualification aux
travailleurs indépendants qu'il revient
aux plateformes de prouver que
l'algorithme n'est pas au coeur de la
relation contractuelle
s'il est question de l'accès à la
protection sociale et à la qualification
juridique sont centrales aucune réponse
on est vraiment idéal tout comme la
proposition créer un statut
intermédiaire rejeté par le sénat en
juin dernier le groupe indépendant
république et territoires est favorable
au renforcement des droits et de
l'indépendance des travailleurs des
plateformes comme le préconise
d'ailleurs le récent rapport
d'information du sénat sur le droit
social
apic la vo travailleur indépendant
publié en mai 2009 gardons à l'esprit
que cette nouvelle forme de travail
particulièrement souple et accessible
permet à des personnes éloignées de
l'emploi d'avoir une source de revenus
substantiels
aussi convient-il de renforcer l'accès
aux droits des travailleurs numérique
notamment à l'égard des complémentaires
santé d assurance-chômage accidents du
travail et maladies professionnelles
cette situation n'est pas dommageable
pour les salariés qui travaillent via
les plateformes pour un complément de
revenu la notion de travailleur
numérique n'est pas toujours synonyme de
dépendance économique ou de précarité
en revanche elle l'est pour les
travailleurs indépendants exclusif qui
ne bénéficient d'aucune couverture
sociale une grande une grande partie de
cette dernière catégorie de travailleurs
correspond à des personnes sans
qualification à des étudiants et parfois
des travailleurs sans papiers à travers
des sous locations de kout
d'auto-entrepreneur moyennant des
rétrocommissions ces dérives existent et
nous devons agir en apportant des
solutions concrètes et ciblées sans pour
autant remettre en cause les
opportunités de développement des
nombreuses plateformes françaises et
européennes
merci de votre attention merci chers
collègues
la parole est maintenant madame raymonde
poncet monge pour le groupe écologiste
pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur madame la ministre
chers collègues cette proposition de loi
s'inscrit dans un mouvement
transformation profonde de notre rapport
au travail dans le contexte de la
transition numérique
les enquêtes de l'oit et la teste
l'aspiration à l'autonomie progresser
employés et motive une partie d'entre
eux à se tourner vers une plate forme
courrier et exercé comme livreur ou
chauffeurs sous le statut d'auto
entrepreneur et sa promesse
d'indépendance pour d'autres il s'agit
simplement de créer son emploi dans un
contexte de chômage massif fermé aux
faibles qualifications exercer son
travail de manière autonome choisir ses
modalités d'organisation son rythme de
travail
ces horaires posséder son outil de
travail ne pas être dans une situation
de subordination
c'est presque un idéal d'émancipation
dans certaines plateformes se vante
d'être le réceptacle seulement ce récit
d'indépendance s'avère bien souvent une
fiction déconstruit par la forme de
rappel d'une exploitation sans
régulation un livreur de taki it easy
témoigner ainsi devant les journalistes
si tu ne dors pas à créneaux tu te
prends un carton
si tu refuses une livraison tu t'en
prends un autre au bout de trois thés
convoqué y as tu tués lee min-hee il
désactive ton qu'on peut contrôler en
temps réel de la course surveillance
constante dans la réalisation de la
tâche
opacité de la fixation des tarifs un
possibilité de choisir les itinéraires
obligation de se connecter régulièrement
à la plateforme sous peine d'être
interdite d'accès dépendance à
l'algorithme tout ceci n'est pas
l'autonomie d'un entrepreneur mais un
renforcement des pouvoirs disciplinaires
ce que les chercheurs appellent le
management algorithmique renvoie bien à
des pratiques de surveillance et de
contrôle qui qualifie une subordination
de fête en angleterre au portugal aux
pays-bas en espagne une série de d
6on de justice a permis aux travailleurs
d'être qualifié en tant que salarié nous
même en france où la vie dit la cour
d'appel de paris a réaffirmé le lien de
subordination en soulignant qu' une
condition essentielle de l'entrepreneur
indépendant se trouve dans la maîtrise
de l'organisation de ces tâches de sa
recherche de clientèle et de
fournisseurs les actions en justice
heurte cependant à la présomption de non
salariat qui laisse aux travailleurs la
charge de la preuve de sa subordination
il est juste que ce soit alors aux
plateformes à prouver que le statut
d'auto entrepreneur n'a pas été
détournée comme il est nécessaire que le
rapport de force et de négociations
fortement défavorables aux travailleurs
isolés soit compensée par la possibilité
d'action collective à laquelle chacun
est libre de s'associer ou pas chacun
est libre aussi parce qu'ils croient
maîtriser son organisation la maîtrise
et que son indépendance et réelle de
rester indépendant et de s'inscrire
sinon de croire à la réduction de la
symétrie du rapport de force avec les
plateformes promise par la négociation à
venir en 2023 mais preuve a été apportée
récemment que le modèle des plateformes
numériques n'est pas remis en cause par
le recours au statut salarial notre
responsabilité législatives alors et de
rendre possible la lutte contre
l'indépendance quand elles s'avèrent
fictives par ailleurs pour répondre au
désir d'autonomie
nous pensons aux groupes écologistes
qu'il faut surtout changer le contenu et
le sens de l'activité changer le travail
mais cela c'est un autre chantier
notre groupe votera cette proposition de
loi je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci jacques oleg la parole est
maintenant monsieur dominique théophile
pour le groupe air des pays pour quatre
minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
la proposition de loi de notre collègue
olivier jacquin propose de lutter contre
l'indépendance fictive des travailleurs
indépendants qui ont recours pour
l'exercice de leur activité
professionnelle à une ou plusieurs
plateformes numériques
ce n'est pas la première fois que notre
assemblée se penche sur ce sujet puisque
deux propositions de loi visant je cite
à rétablir les droits sociaux des
travailleurs numérique
on va faire évoluer leur statut ont été
récemment débattue parce que le
développement de ce système
ces systèmes de mise en relation a connu
une évolution rapide ces dernières
années parce que le nombre de
travailleurs qui ont recours n'a cessé
d'augmenter et qu'il est de notre
responsabilité de faire évoluer le cadre
juridique qui l'accompagnent vous
proposer d'abord d'étendre les actions
de groupe aux procédures de vos
qualifications
ce dispositif nous semble pourtant posé
un certain nombre de difficultés
d'accord d'abord parce qu'il existe
autant de cas de figure possibles que
deux plateformes et de travailleurs et
qu'une solution unique ne nous semble
pas adéquat
ensuite parce que les décisions des
différentes cours d'appel et des
conseils des prud'hommes ont démontré
que le droit existant répondit je
répondais déjà en assurant la prise en
compte du caractère unique de chaque
situation en partie aux attentes des
travailleurs
enfin et surtout parce qu'il nous semble
abusif de considérer que la
requalification des travailleurs est une
demande pleinement partagée si les
chiffres nous montrent il apparaît
clairement qu'une majorité des
travailleurs indépendants souhaitent en
effet conserver les l'agilité que leur
permet leur statut les conclusions de la
mission
mettling qui s'est penché sur les
modalités de mise en oeuvre du dialogue
social entre les plateformes
il est aux travailleurs ne dit
d'ailleurs pas autre chose parce que les
revendications des travailleurs se prête
mal à des mesures uniforme
il nous semble donc
préférable de privilégier le dialogue
social et la concertation qui sont les
plus à même d'imposer de nouveaux doigts
et de garantir des mesures
proportionnées et fidèle aux réalités
spécifiques des travailleurs des
plateformes
c'est notamment l'objet de l' ordonnance
du 21 avril 2021 relative aux modalités
de représentation des travailleurs
indépendants que vous venez madame la
ministre d'évoquer j'y reviendrai dans
quelques instants vous proposer ensuite
de supprimer la présomption de nos
salariés à un tas de management
algorithmes éthique vous souhaiter pour
cela procéder à la réfection complète de
l'article l 8221 tirer 6 du code du
travail
là encore la rédaction que vous suggérez
nous semble problématique en recentrant
le dispositif sur la place de
l'algorithme vous excluez dans les faits
les travailleurs indépendants qui y ont
pas recours
nous devrons ainsi prouver l'absence de
lien de subordination juridique
en plus d'être initialement établie
comme des travailleurs salariés
si nous n'adhérons pas à la méthode il
nous semble en revanche important que le
cadre juridique qui encadre les
relations professionnelles entre les
travailleurs indépendants et les plates
formes puissent évoluer dans la lignée
de la loi à travail
la loi d'orientation des mobilités a
ainsi introduit de nouvelles garanties
au bénéfice des travailleurs numérique
en renforçant leur indépendance ou leurs
doigts à la formation professionnelle
c'est le cas également de l' ordonnance
du 21 avril 2021 qui fait l'autorité des
relations sociales des plates formes
d'emploi en emploi chargée de réguler
les relations sociales entre les
plateformes et les travailleurs
indépendants
ces apports nous les avons voté ils
doivent maintenant porter leurs fruits
et chers collègues parce que ces
avancées de mode du temps et que le
dialogue social nous semble le plus à
même d'assurer aux travailleurs des
plateformes numériques les doigts que
leur statut
et pendant leur garantit notre groupe ne
votera pas cette proposition je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur henri cabanel pour
le groupe r d est ce pour quatre minutes
le président à madame la ministre mes
chers collègues je tiens avant tout à
remercier notre collègue olivier jacquin
et le groupe socialiste écologique et
républicaine de nous donner une nouvelle
fois l'occasion de nous pencher sur la
délicate question des travailleurs des
plateformes numériques
c'est plate forme en tout début
prométhée l'eldorado et ont dépensé
beaucoup d'argent pour que ce mythe soit
réalité et plateformes proposer des
rémunérations particulièrement
alléchante provoquant un véritable
engouement être son propre bâton était
par ailleurs une idée très séduisante
mais cette liberté a un prix et ib
risation grimm aujourd'hui avec
précarisation font décidément les
conditions d'emploi se sont en effet
dégradé oblige à la plupart de ces
travailleurs à travailler plus pour
gagner moins
numérisation du monde du travail fait
voler en éclats tous les acquis sociaux
obtenus depuis près de deux siècles
comme l'a rappelé jamie le fouet dans
son rapport remis au premier ministre en
décembre dernier les plateformes
numériques de travail favorisera
l'apparition d'une nouvelle classe de
travailleurs précaires
si ce nouveau secteur constitue l'un des
plus grands bouleversements du marché du
travail de la dernière décennie
il cache surtout un modèle économique
ultralibéral qui se développe au
détriment du droit du travail heures de
ses plateformes digitales
nous sommes tous d'accord pour
reconnaître que la protection sociale
des travailleurs indépendants est très
insuffisante ne sont pas couverts au
titre de l'assurance chômage et ne
cotisez généralement pas pour leur
retraite ils ne sont pas couverts par la
branche accidents du travail et maladies
professionnelles est nommé déficit pas
non plus de la généralisation de la
couverture maladie complémentaire
ils sont pourtant exposé le nombre de
risques professionnels
combien d'entre nous n'ont jamais croisé
deux livreurs à scooter à vélo ou autre
roulant à toute vitesse un sens interdit
pour pouvoir effectuer au plus vite leur
livraison est enchaîné la suivante
les livraisons se sont transformés en
véritable course au premier sens du
terme
la raison est simple les conditions
tarifaires ans on ne se sont peu à peu
dégradée
même s'il est difficile de savoir dans
quelle proportion puisque le tarif de
chaque course est calculée par les
algorithmes ces mêmes algorithmes dans
l'opus l'opacité est régulièrement
pointé du doigt les plateformes les
utilise en effet notamment pour
attribuer le travail des récompenses les
livreurs incapable de suivre le rythme
ou qui refusent les missions sont
pénalisés voir écartés comme l'a rappelé
notre collègue ghislaine pantel l'année
dernière
la technologie a évolué plus vite que
notre droit et il existe aujourd'hui une
joie de devis du juridique entre statut
de salarié et le statut d'indépendant
c'est dans cet esprit que la cour de
cassation 2018 puis en 2020 a estimé
qu'un lien de subordination existait
bien entre les travailleurs et la
plateforme
c'est pourquoi la commission européenne
réfléchit également aux moyens de mieux
protéger les travailleurs des
plateformes numériques
certes l'ordonnancé du 21 avril 2021
marque une première étape en permettant
les élections des représentants du
personnel les secteurs de vtc et de
livraison de courses au plus tard le 31
décembre 2022
mais à l'heure où l'espagne vient de
reconnaître le statut de salarié de
plein droit pour les coursiers des
plateformes de livraison de repas à
domicile
il est impérieux de remettre l'humain au
centre des débats et d'offrir à ces
travailleurs hub et reese est une
véritable protection pour qu'il ne soit
pas selon les mots de l'écrivain
kamel amellal les prolétaires du 21e
siècle
c'est pourquoi dans sa grande majorité
le groupe rdse soutiendra cette
proposition de loi qui permet aux
travailleurs de plateformes d exercer
une action de groupe et qui institue la
présomption de salariat je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur pascal
savoldelli pour le groupe crc e pour 4
minutes
le président
ah oui parce que moi j'ai déjà timide
alors déjà je le président revol des
limes fait remarquer qu'il est déjà
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues en juin
2020 autre groupe crc wade a présenté
une proposition de loi sur le statut de
ces travailleurs elle a été d'ailleurs
évoqué je vous en remercie mes chers
collègues
elle visait 1 à les intégrer au code du
travail
mon sens lors ouvrir le droit à une
protection sociale
tout le monde en parle est un droit à la
négociation collective
on en a évoqué aussi tout le monde sait
ici à quel point ces travailleurs sont
précaires y compris la cour de cassation
qui les a reconnus par deux fois comme
salariés déguisés parquet ce qui s'est
passé le gouvernement il s'est comporté
à l'époque comme le vrp des plateformes
et ça a été confirmé cet après-midi par
vos propos madame la ministre
votre boussole celle essayer d'obtenir
un tiers statut on a eu la chance après
midi grâce au débat proposé d'avoir la
méthode du gouvernement
c'est quoi ces les ordonnances nous sont
présentés après donc bravo pour votre
exposé madame la ministre
il était très explicite le groupe
socialiste lui s'étaient abstenus
juillet revenir et alors nos collègues
de droite ce que j'appelle la majorité
c'est dental des droites à chaque fois
qu'on vient ce sujet c'est le statu quo
on touche à rien mes camarades
socialistes s'étaient abstenus la
dernière fois et vous comprenez un peu
notre étonnement quand même dans votre
cheminement des fois puisque des fois
c'est le regroupement coopératif
d'emplois et d'activités après vous
évoquez le devoir de vigilance
et maintenant la requalification par
action de groupe tout ça pour finalement
reprendre à demi-mot notre travail porte
dont acte de vos intentions mais le
contenu reste quelque peu chaotique et
questionnant l'efficacité de son
application emprunt d'optimiste j'ai
bien noté dans votre article 1er vouliez
donner à ces travailleurs la possibilité
d'intenter une procédure de
requalification par action group lors
donnant ainsi un outil supplémentaire
pour faire respecter les droits
nous encourageons votre volonté de
remplacer la présomption de non sanaria
par une présomption de contrat de
travail dans votre article 2 c'était
notre idée
il me serait donc difficile de vous
contredire et serait bien inutile de se
départager
enfin autre article 3 vient renforcer
l'expertisé des conseils des plus nobles
en leur donnant la possibilité
d'ordonner aux plateformes de
communiquer leurs algorithmes de se
faire assister d'un expert pour la
compréhension de son fonctionnement
nous avions proposé l'année dernière que
les travailleurs puissent eux-mêmes se
faire assister d'un data ou d'une date à
scientiste c'était bien plus offensif en
termes de démocratie sociale dans cet
article 3 on perçoit une certaine
confusion
d'abord vous parlez des plateforme de
mise en relation alors là c'est non
c'est pas acceptable et une mise au
point est indispensable mes chers
collègues les plateformes les plus
précaires précarisant tu celle qui
justement appelle à protéger les
travailleurs les hubert lê des libéraux
et cetera sont tout sauf des plateforme
de mise en relation
ce sont des plateformes numériques du
travail pour une plateforme peut
sanctionner un travailleur parce qu'il
n'a pas respecté un itinéraire qu'elle
impose ses tarifs et qu'elle ait dit ses
factures on est au delà de la mise en
relation on est dans la gestion et du
contrôle les plateformes doivent
impérativement assumer leurs
responsabilités d'employeur et
s'acquitter des cotisations sociales
concernant l'article 1er l'action de
groupe
elle limite l'indemnisation puisque
seuls les préjudices née après la
demande sont pris en considération
elle transfère le contentieux social du
juge prud'homal au juge judiciaire et
tout le monde sait ici que ce n'est pas
la même lecture du droit
la logique est la même pour votre
article 2 sur les critères de
présomptions du contrat de travail ou
proposé qu'au moins les deux tiers du
revenu professionnel annuel résulte un
algorithme est une et je cite une
exploitation directe ou indirecte par
une personne je vois pas comment peut
être exploité directement ou
indirectement par une personne s'est pas
tout à fait claires et sur la question
des algorithmes qui a repris madame la
ministre je pense qu'il faut qu'on aille
beaucoup plus loin il faut mettre des
critères sinon c'est ce que j'appelle la
gauche une ordination qui sont définies
c'est un enjeu majeur madame la ministre
ces plateformes choisissent de contrôler
par la gorille les éléments essentiels
de la relation de travail et pas
seulement la relation contractuelle
cette absence de définition limite
considérablement la portée de cet
article
donc vous l'avez compris ça avec
beaucoup de réserve mais nous voterons
favorablement votre proposition nous la
voterons pour que le débat et
s'élargissent pour le débat se clarifie
c'est l'intérêt pour ces nouveaux
salariés des salariés déguisés et
méprisés merci merci
la parole est maintenant madame monique
lubin pour le groupe socialiste pour six
minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur rapporteur sert collègues
aujourd'hui permettez moi de vous parler
d'isaac vous le connaissez sûrement pas
mais il a axé le nom d'un nouveau chef
d'equipe avec lequel plus de 130 mille
travailleurs de 1000 entreprises
collaborent et ce dans près de 100 pays
différents
il a conclu qu'une fonction très
précises il doit être capable de mesurer
les activités de ses collègues en
fournissant en temps réel des
renseignements sur le comportement et
sur la productivité de chaque salarié
il est ainsi capable de produire des
rapports détaillés de l'influencé des
comportements individuels sur la
performance de l'entreprise
c'est ainsi qu'ils ac est devenu le bras
droit de milliers de managers qui
peuvent désormais s'appuyer sur les
nombreux et précieux renseignements
distiller afin d'attribuer
quotidiennement une note individuelle à
chaque employé sur la base des
évaluations subjectives
pourtant contrairement à tous ses
collègues
isaac s'affranchit des tâches qui
incombent chaque jour à des millions de
travailleurs
en effet s'il n'a pas besoin de régler
son réveil chaque veille de journée de
travail
ils ne se soucient guère plus
accompagner ses enfants à l'école ou
bien de l'entretien de son foyer
en réalité il
ac ne possède ni visage ni corps et
détient comme seules caractéristiques
humaines son nom chers collègues vous
l'aurez compris isaac est un algorithme
si ces créateurs tenté naïvement de nous
le présenter comme un instrument visant
à garantir le bien-être des salariés
étant capable de détecter des charges de
travail excessive
il n'apparaît pas difficile d'imaginer
les dérives évidente qui peuvent
découler de ce type de logiciel car en
réalité isaac s'inscrit parfaitement
dans une économie de précision qui
lisent à l'unique recherche d'une
maximisation du rendement en croisant
simultanément un nombre incalculable de
données et cela bien souvent au
détriment de la santé mentale et du
bien-être des travailleurs qui
n'hésitent pas à abandonner pose est
temps de réflexion ne souhaitant surtout
pas paraître comme passif aux yeux du
logiciel et par extension à ceux de
leurs managers et dirigeants
ce contrôle fin du rendement de chacun
sert à la frénétique économie de
l'individualisation rampante alors avec
la trajectoire historique selon laquelle
la convention collective était utilisé
pour rééquilibrer les rapports de force
entre travailleurs et employeurs
et c'est là au péril de nombreuses
grandes luttes sociales passé l'effet
que je vous expose présentement ne
relève en rien d'une fiction
ils dépeignent une monrose réalité à
laquelle un nombre croissant de
travailleurs sont exposés
quotidiennement dans ce nouvel univers
du travail marquées par la gigue
économie en connectant des services déjà
existants rendu possible grâce à une
solution de technologiques nouvelles ces
plateformes sont venus transformé de
nombreux secteurs d'activité elles ont
certes permis une diversification de
l'offre mais souvent au détriment des
cadres de régulation classique
précarisant la condition de certains
travailleurs et bas-fonds leurs droits
sociaux fondamentaux
ce sont ainsi plusieurs milliers de
travailleurs qui ont été séduits par les
promesses de ces plateformes qui
garantissent une organisation libre du
temps de travail sans contrainte et
hiérarchique mais bien souvent à cette
illusion de liberté se situe se
substitue une réalité bien plus brutale
car les travailleurs des plateformes se
retrouve très rapidement pieds et poings
liés face aux exige
des plateformes les clients sont imposés
les tracés devienne obligatoire et les
sanctions à l'encontre de ces
travailleurs sont nombreuses du jour au
lendemain certains travailleurs voient
leur compte suspendu bien souvent sans
aucune justification de la part des
plateformes et en privé de nombreux
droits sociaux du fait du statut fictif
l'indépendant il ne leur reste bien
souvent plus que leurs yeux pour pleurer
ces pratiques sont d'autant plus cruel
lorsqu'on observe que ces travailleurs
souvent sans formation sont
économiquement contraint par le marché
et ne dispose guère d'autres
perspectives de revenus que ces
plateformes
c'est d'ailleurs l'une des principales
raisons pour lesquelles les banlieues
particulièrement touchés par la
précarité sont devenus les principales
pourvoyeuses de main d'oeuvre des
plateformes de l'été c'est mais tout
l'enjeu se trouve désormais dans la
maîtrise ces nouveaux algorithmes qui
selon les projections constitueront la
principale source de revenus de près
d'un demi milliard d'individus sur la
planète d'ici 2025
il est alors de notre responsabilité de
garder la mainmise sur ses innovations
technologiques avant de nous faire
dépasser par celle-ci encadrer et
contrôler et elles doivent être
désormais les maîtres mots lorsqu'il est
question de six plateformes numériques
c'est un texte marque et d'humilité que
nous vous présentons aujourd'hui car il
ne prétend aucunement révolutionner les
fondements de l'économie 2.0 mais
simplement garantir les droits dus à ces
travailleurs qui ne sont indépendants
que par la qualification juridique de
leur contrat imposé par les plateformes
on entend souvent dire que les
travailleurs des plateformes seraient
volontaires désireux de liberté
il n'aurait pas envie d'un rapport de
salariat
s'il est vrai que c'est le cas pour une
partie d'entre nous devons rester
vigilants à ce que ce sentiment de
liberté ne se constitue pas en miroir
aux alouettes
et pour cause la réalité sera bien cruel
lorsque ces salariés voudront faire
valoir leurs droits sociaux et notamment
leurs droits à la retraite et se sont
alors de nombreux foyers qui se
retrouveront plongé dans une extrême
précarité
nous devons ne pas croire ces
plateformes lorsqu elles prétendent que
notre modèle social est inenvisageable
et pour preuve certaines entreprises de
livraison de repas sont aujourd'hui
capables de proposer des contrats de
salariat
leurs employés nous devons également
agir pour toutes les entreprises du
numérique pour qu'ils proposent
aujourd'hui les solutions plus éthique
et plus juste vis-à-vis des travailleurs
mais qui se retrouve dépassée par les
pratiques déloyales des sociétés
concurrentes qui recourent tu d'un ping
sociale sans plus se cacher combien de
temps allons-nous fermer les yeux sur
l'exploitation de ces personnes de ces
jeunes de ces immigrés de ces étranges
et parfois en situation irrégulière
combien de temps allons-nous continuer à
dire que les questions sont bonnes mais
que les réponses ne le sont pas il est
temps d'avancer et il apparaît très
nettement que face à toutes ces dérives
la meilleure solution reste le salariat
pour éviter que ne se dresse pour ces
milliers de travailleurs le spectre du
retour du taschereau nage du 19e siècle
que nous nous sommes attelés à
déconstruire par le biais de nombreux
combats sociaux
est ce cela que nous voulons
certainement pas nous devons agir pour
ses esclaves pour ces nouveaux esclaves
21e siècle
merci madame la ministre vous souhaitez
répondre si je puis me permettre c'est
pas la tradition mais si vous pouviez
répondre de manière brève parce que la
contrainte de l'exercice ces cas 16h04
j'arrête le texte socialiste donc il
faudrait y soit voté quoi merci vous
envoyer non non mais je vais répondre je
vous réponds très bon moi je voudrais
dire je voudrais dire à mon tour que je
pense qu'on est sur un sujet important
qui mérite mieux que des caricatures
alors il n'y a pas d'un côté ceux qui
voudraient défendre le droit d'être à
les droits des travailleurs et puis de
l'autre ceux qui défendrait aveuglément
les plateformes ces plateformes
elles ont permis de faire émerger des
nouveaux services de créer des noms des
nouveaux emplois et en même temps je
pense que personne ici ne peut se
satisfaire de la précarité d'un certain
nombre de travailleurs qu'on peut tous
observé y compris en circulant dans
notre espace public aujourd'hui avec des
livreurs qui devrait être à vélo qui
sont en scooter et dont un certain
nombre sont manifestement exploité
donc on partage ce constat ensuite on
doit trouver un chemin effectivement
pour permettre le développement de ces
emplois en répondant
aspirations des travailleurs qui ne
veulent pas nécessairement être des
salariés et en renforçant les droits
individuels et collectifs de ses
travailleurs
et c'est bien le chemin que nous prenons
depuis le début du quinquennat avec
l'objectif de rétablir le rapport de
force entre les plateformes et les
travailleurs c'est notamment ce qui
était prévu dans la loi d'orientation
des mobilités avec un droit à la
déconnexion pour les travailleurs des
plateformes avec la possibilité de
refuser des courses avec la possibilité
qu'il peut paraître élémentaire de
connaître la distance et le prix d'une
course avant de l'accepter et c'est ce
même chemin que nous continuons en
permettant de construire une
représentation de ces travailleurs pour
pouvoir engager une négociation
collective et nous allons également
continuer en renforçant les droits de
ces travailleurs j'ai évoqué notamment
le sujet des accidents de travail et des
maladies professionnelles pour lequel
manifestement il nous faut renforcer ses
protections et puis dernier point c'est
bien de faire des lois est aussi bien de
les contrôler et je peux vous redire que
les services de mon ministère sont
mobilisés pour précisément contrôler et
sanctionner les abus qui peuvent exister
dans un certain nombre de domaines
donc voilà monsieur le sénateur mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
je peux vous dire que je pense qu'il
s'est réellement un sujet important sur
lequel nous cherchons la voie dans un
domaine nouveau et vraiment ça mérite
mieux que des caricatures la commission
n'ayant pas élaboré de textes nous
passons la discussion des articles de la
proposition de loi initiale à l'article
je ne suis pas saisi d'amendements ni de
prise de parole mais en revanche je suis
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe l'est républicain
il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement
un peu de calme un peu de calme à l'est
le scrutin est ouvert sur l'article
numéro un
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifié la présidence nombre de votants
330 nombre de suffrages exprimés 312
pour l'adoption 86 contre 226 le sénat
n'a pas adopté à l'article 2 je suis
saisi d'une demande de parole par le
président caennais monsieur le président
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre est rapidement on a évoqué le
notion de caricatures je ne sais pas si
je serai caricatural mais je reconnais
qu'il est difficile d'être un ministre
de gauche dans un gouvernement de droite
mais c'est votre choix ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas le nôtre
je dis simplement que cette ce texte
cette proposition de loi
après une autre que nous avons porté
avec mon ami ben et monsieur jacques 1 a
déjà il ya quelques mois celle portée
par le groupe communiste
nous voulons alerter finalement
l'opinion et ne vous en déplaise pendant
la ministre nous avons le droit au
parlement d'imaginer des solutions qui
peut être vous semblent insuffisantes et
non peut-être juridiquement suffisamment
à 6
vous avez dit mais j'ai la réponse
permettez que nous ayons aussi notre
réponse
naturellement vous l'avez évoqué sur un
ton qui je crois aurait mérité peut-être
non pas de la compassion à notre égard
mais en tout cas un minimum peut-être de
compréhension sur la démarche que nous
avons initié
donc nous savons quel est le sort qui
sera réservé par la droite sénatoriale à
laquelle vous apportez votre votre
support mais nous continuerons à
défendre ses salariés parce qu'une
pension qu'il s'agit de salariés
il s'agit de salariés dans dans les
faits et que la jurisprudence y compris
internationale nous donne de plus en
plus raison encore une fois
l'étape que nous portons avec cette
proposition de loi vise à clarifier et
finalement les relations entre ce que
nous considérons être les employeurs est
ce que nous considérons être des
salariés de plus en plus et la question
de la liberté qui a été souvent évoqué y
compris par mam lubin il ya quelques
instants
je crois ne concerne une extrême
minorité de celles et ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui dans cette situation vous ne
partagez pas c'est ce sentiment vous en
avez le droit permettait simplement au
groupe socialiste d'imaginer des
solutions contraire en tout cas avec
cette proposition de loi
c'est une première pierre je le disais
dans le débat sur l'avenir du travail
lié aux plateformes liés à cette
évolution de la société qui pour nous
n'est pas un progrès mais que nous
constatons comme un fait acquis
aujourd'hui et qu'il faut absolument
améliorer par l'encadrement juridique
que nous proposons voilà l'esprit dans
lequel nous défendons l'article 2 de
cette proposition de l'autre et par
monsieur savoldelli prise de parole avec
votre enthousiasme assuré monsieur le
président comme on est dans la situation
qui risquait d'avoir les 3 2 les
articles vont pas être votée donc on
n'aura pas à voter la loi dont il y aura
pas d'explications de vote
c'est pas une question de posture madame
la ministre
voilà vous êtes peut-être quelqu'un que
je respecte votre travail votre parcours
vous connaissez le sens des mots donc
quand vous parler d'emploi vous parler
des emplois de salariés à des livres ou
d'accor a eu berrer a eu l'air des
salariés des contrats cds emploi ça tous
les autres c'est pas des emplois madame
la ministre
c'est des activités rémunérées bina mais
attendez vous n'êtes pas n'importe quel
ministre et vous savez ici qu'on est
dans le devoir d du sens des mots quand
même nom les plateformes numériques de
travail ne crée pas d'emplois madame la
ministre
sinon se poserait pas la question de la
subordination sinon se poserait pas la
question de contrat de travail
voyez c'est ça la question mais face
qu'il ya un moment faut quand même je
veux dire dans le débat avec beaucoup de
respect et d'écouté ce que je fais aussi
moi il ya un moment les mots ont un sens
ces plateformes numériques de travail ne
crée pas des emplois
il crée des activités avec
des rémunérations avec des algorithmes
vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure qui
n'était pas au coeur du sujet mais les
algorithmes sont au coeur du sujet vous
savez mieux que moi ce que c'est un
algorithme c'est une suite
c'est une méthode de résolution d'un
problème donc les plateformes ont posé
un problème on prie l'outil
technologique et l'on versées en
fonction de leurs objectifs
donc arrêtons de dire ça à deux des
travailleurs indépendants midi sont
dépeints indépendante quoi mes chers
collègues à telle heure vous allez
livrer les sushis vous livrer lés quatre
protège chez le dentiste comme ça et il
ya un orage et caetera et vous êtes
rémunéré temps ils sont indépendants de
quoi vous connaissez des gens ils payent
ils payent cobos indépendants ils payent
leur vélo lors sutil le scooter etc etc
ils sont indépendants de quoi donc c'est
pas des travailleurs indépendants non
plus donc il faut qu'on ait un débat
passionné aiguisé j'ai bien vu
conflictuelle mais il faut qu'on ait
faut qu on s
ce débat est alors moi je vous le dit
madame la ministre
il faut qu on souffre tous d'humilité et
j'en ai aussi on peut avoir est un homme
deux roues une femme de conviction avoir
une forte personnalité politique
moi j'ai rencontré pas mal de
travailleurs de ces plateformes jus des
débats vifs des conflits sur autonomy
sur indépendance allait discuter avec
eux de votre ordonnance sur le dialogue
social
on y va ensemble on y va ici à
représentant par groupe et vous madame
la ministre
et on va sur des places des grandes
métropoles et on va discuter avec les
travailleurs des plateformes numériques
et là on va voir s'ils veulent pas être
protégé s'ils veulent pas de congé
maternité s'ils veulent pas de congés de
maladie s'ils veulent pas de retraite
s'ils veulent pas négocier leur salaire
l'enverrai les verrines et savoldelli
respecter le règlement du sénat est
resté sur votre temps de parole c'est
la énième fois je vous le dis je crois
avec toute la sympathie que j'ai pour ce
que ça vaut lever bien s'il n'ya pas
d'auto de la ministre je vais finir par
faire voter le texte
mais à madame la ministre non en tant
que ministre du travail et de l'emploi
j'essaye de comprendre le sens des mots
et l'emploi c'est pas forcément l'emploi
salarié et le travail c'est pas
forcément le salariat et vous savez il
ya de plus en plus de jeunes qui veulent
créer leur propre emploi qui veulent
être des travailleurs indépendants et
puis discuter avec les travailleurs des
plateformes monsieur le sénateur j'ai
pas attendu vous me invitiez pour le
faire monsieur savoldelli savoldelli
vous continuer sa série vous continuerez
ça sur votre site facebook allait sur
l'article 2 sur l'article 2 je suis
saisi par le groupe les républicaine
d'une demande de scrutin public
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
voici le résultat du scrutin 128 sur la
sur l'article 2
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs ou aux politiques et notifiée
à la présidence nombre de votants 330
nombre de suffrages exprimés 327 pour
l'adoption sein contre 226 le sénat n'a
pas adopté
et je passe à l'article 3 où je suis
saisi d'une demande de parole de
monsieur jacques 1
eh bien faites pas une photo en même
temps
j'avais envie de vous prendre en photo
c'est le président brièvement brièvement
je sais pas s'il y aura encore du temps
de parole après le troisième scrutin
public et j'explique à ceux qui suivent
le débat cette situation étrange où il
ya une majorité de gauche physiquement
présente que je tiens à saluer et à
remercier je tiens à remercier les
quelques collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale qui sont venus physiquement
ici mais là il s'utilise une procédure
qui me permet de faire voter les absents
au débat donc nous sommes minoritaires
mais c'est pas ça l'essentiel
l'essentiel ces échanges sur ce sujet
important
ces échanges de qualité quelquefois vif
et encore heureux nous sommes vraiment
pas sur les mêmes positions
je le répète certains défendre les
plateformes et puis d'autres les
travailleurs des plateformes tout le
monde a dit qu'il y avait un problème
une précarité mais voilà vous choisissez
votre camp cependant dans ce débat
madame la ministre tient à vous
remercier pour vos apports sur la
question que vous avez posé l'autre jour
lors des questions au gouvernement sur
le fait de saisir l'inspection du
travail
donc ça va dans le bon sens il ya encore
à faire beaucoup pour être dans un
véritable état de droit je pense aux non
recours de l'urssaf
alors que l'arrêt de la cour de
cassation qui a pointé des secteurs
entiers où il y a un défaut de
cotisations je pense au non-respect de
la question du rgp des et du problème de
l'exploitation des données des ces
travailleurs la question subtil de la
loyauté des contrats ou encore
l'exercice du droit de concurrence
lorsqu'il y à dialogue social je vous
remercie aussi d'avoir clarifié votre
position parce que ce gouvernement par à
ordonnance pour un parlementaire c'est
extrêmement désagréable aussi que sur la
démocratie et vous avez bien déroulée
votre programme très clairement je ne
crois pas vous avoir quatre briques à
thuré en disant clairement que vous
avancez vers un nouveau statut ce que la
mission froid ne voulait pas pour ne pas
créer deux frontières floues
là où il y en a une actuellement entre
salariés et indépendants de créer un
nouveau tiers statut avec les droits low
cost comme les anglais l'ont fait comme
les italiens l'avaient fait ou les
espagnols de walkers un nouveau
prolétariat sans garantie de revenu et
avec des droits sociaux aux rabat et
j'ai bien compris que la question se
jouerait aussi partiellement en europe
autant pour les travailleurs du clic qui
ne sont pas territorialisée il ya
nécessité de ces régulations européennes
de même que sur l'algorithme
par contre pour ce qu'on appelle la giga
factory qui est territorialisée ici on
n'a pas à attendre
l'europe on a un droit du travail
français qui nous permet de réguler je
vous remercie
merci je vais mettre en voix l'article 3
sur lequel il n'y a pas de lendemain je
vous rappelle que si cet article était
rejetée ignorer naturellement pas de
vote sur l'ensemble du texte puisque les
trois articles seraient rejetés pas
d'autres demandes d'explications pas
d'autres demandes de prise de parole sur
l'article 3 très bien je mets aux voix
l'article 3 par scrutin public est la
demande à nouveau du groupe l'est
républicain
voici le résultat du scrutin sur
l'article 3 compte tenu de l'ensemble
des délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 343 nombre de suffrages exprimés
340 pour l'adoption sein contre 239 le
sénat n'a pas adopté les articles de la
proposition de loi ont été
successivement supprimé par le sénat je
constate qu'un vote sur l'ensemble n'est
pas nécessaire puisqu'il n'y a plus de
texte en conséquence la proposition de
loi n'est pas adoptée
[Musique]